Donald Trump has famously said so many times,
you must respect the flag.
You must respect the national Anthem.
You must stand at attention during the national
Anthem.
Anything but total unflinching devotion to
the national Anthem is unpatriotic.
And now a video has leaked of Donald Trump
at a Superbowl party Sunday at Mar-a-Lago,
laughing, fidgeting, pretending to do, uh,
like he is conducting like a conductor, uh,
during the national Anthem pointing at people.
And at one point where the video, I'm going
to play cuts appearing to be actually starting
to sit down while the national Anthem is playing.
Take a look at this video.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible]
you might've noticed that the video cuts when
Trump appears to be just going to sit down
while the national Anthem is still playing.
But don't you dare kneel during the national
Anthem if you're a football player, it actually
looks like the video was specifically edited
to remove Donald Trump sitting down during
the national Anthem.
So what does this tell us?
The entire salute, the flag, respect the Anthem
stuff from Trump is nonsense.
Trump can't stand still for it.
He's fidgeting as much as a toddler.
Something seems very much wrong with the guy,
but he's also making other people's lives
miserable over what they do during the national
Anthem.
While he behaves like a kid during it, while
he behaves in the way he claims is disrespectful
and uh, actually said, get that son of a bitch
outta here or whatever the case was because
of what people did during the national Anthem,
he's goofing around like a board, toddler,
while foreigner, Melania Trump stands there
with her hand over her heart and tries to
get Trump to behave like an adult.
And again, it does seem like the behavior
of someone on some kind of upper, like an
Adderall type thing or some other kind of
stimulant.
We don't know.
We never know.
Just imagine for a second, if Barack Obama
was caught on video behaving like this during
the national Anthem, it would be that anti-American
Muslim, unpatriotic, foreigner, Obama disrespecting
the flag and the Anthem and the troops.
And Ronald Reagan and everything's just being
disrespected.
If Barack Obama does it, no, but it's Trump.
So who cares?
You know what I thought when I saw this?
We are definitely not in Kansas city, Kansas
anymore, if you know what I mean.
Now, even more hilariously, the video was
posted by a real estate agent for a Russian
American firm that often hangs out at Donald
Trump's Mar-a-Lago resort.
Just every detail is hilarious and tragic.
Why is a Russian always involved?
Why are Russians always hanging out at Mar-a-Lago?
Fixtures at Donald Trump's events?
This is one of those things I think I've learned
when it comes to the Anthem.
It's only disrespectful if you're a Democrat
or you're black or you're a football player,
but when you're a 73 year old Republican president
like Donald Trump, it's all totally cool to
behave this way during the national Anthem,
this same people who said they were disgusted
by Colin Kaepernick, kneeling in protest during
the Anthem, say nothing about what Donald
Trump does in this video.
I actually suspected, this is really funny.
I suspected when I saw this, Trumpists will
defend Trump.
They'll say Trump is not in the room where
the Anthem is being performed.
Trump's at Mar-a-Lago watching the Anthem
on TV.
It's actually being performed in Miami at
the Superbowl, so it's okay not to stand or
to fidget or to point at people and I decided
it was a risk, but I did it.
I went into the Trumpist enclaves of the internet
yesterday and this is exactly what they were
saying, guys, you've got to cool off.
Trump's not in the room where the Anthem is
being performed.
If he did this in that situation, it would
be disrespectful.
Trump's at Mar-a-Lago, they're just watching
it on TV.
When football players do it, the Anthem is
being performed there.
Trump and Mar-a-Lago were watching the Anthem
on TV, so the rules are different.
The etiquette is completely different and
Donald Trump is completely exonerated.
But when a black football player kneeled for
the national Anthem, that was too much.
Once again, I got emails from people saying,
I have family members with dementia.
When people in their seventies appear have
this fidgety sort of ADHD behavior.
It's not usually ADHD.
It's usually some form of dementia.
And once again, we don't know.
We don't know because no serious evaluation
of the president has been done.